oh ma tête j'ai trop bu hier au puy pas
chez moi j'ai encore dormi je savais que
je connais pas ouais ouais j'aurais pu
pleurer c'était plus sage et bien un
petit café alors si c'est ça c'est pour
le petit déjeuner sous lens
comment vous appelez à vous aussi si
d'accord ça me rassure un an parce que
moi non plus je me rappelle pas de votre
prénom
ah d'accord on est dans le même état
parfait est sacrément bon bah moi je
m'appelle florence voilà je suis je suis
humoriste je pense que vous le savez
quand même et vous où je travaille 10
ans pour le gouvernement c'est à dire
gouvernement qui sait que ça n'a jamais
paru si vous avez été désigné maîtresse
de cérémonie des césars gouvernement qui
gère les césar je suis obligé de dire
oui mais alors tu as des parce que déjà
voyons si je suis disponible ça paraît
c'est quand cette petite fête et sûrs
dans une ère ah bah non mais oui mais
alors vous vous débarquez comme ça
gouvernement là dans une heure ça se
prépare quand même moi je peux pas tout
apprendre en une heure ou alors il faut
que j'en quelqu'un bon mais ces cinq
minutes
la merde bon ben la faveur n'a joué très
serré je le sais cérès et ça c'est à
dire serré qu'à passer de maintenance et
frappé d'un geste dit rappelant
notamment par la poussée du gouvernement
vous aussi puis tu vas pour me dire
bonjour bonsoir peut-être plus non pas
si je peux me permettre parce que les
césars comme seydou ba ba bonjour
bonjour amis des césars bonjour et à
part bonjour c'est quoi le secret dont
surtout aurait en fait c'est leur parle
de papon 2,7 à huy deux des comédiens
bien sûr des acteurs évidemment c'est
leur soirée je vais leur parler d'eux je
peux les vannes est quand même un peu
non enfin je pourrais faire des petites
blagues
sinon on s'ennuie c'est aussi en sorte
dans certains patients et bien sûr la
compassion est vide et syrie pas
imaginer je fais un gros bide tu fais
quoi presque là il doit être plié à
moins que ça tu sais que tu me plais
guette déjà énoncé pas entendu excuse
moi tu sais que tu me plais guette
je vous exagérez quand même bon vas
fougères merci j'avais appris à dire
bonjour compassion et en cas de vide
regard lointain
le chou
je vais écouter en fait c'est moi qui
présente les césar c'est cette année ça
a l'air de vous mettre en joie et en
fait j'avais envie de faire une petite
chorégraphie à un moment parce que je
trouve que techniquement je gagne donc
pas technique mais pourquoi en anglais
là tout d'un coup se désole jeu
franchement je me fiche éperdument
technique alors c'était mieux avant
parce que là vous êtes tous des
synchronisée et qui vous double c'est ça
va pas durer avec votre physique face et
pas la boîte bon bref je voulais juste
savoir si vous vouliez me donner un
petit coup de main pour la chorégraphie
de toute façon j'ai déjà choisi veronica
roddick a indiqué mme aubry pour
présenter les césar alors là vous êtes
complètement à côté de la plaque
elle n'a pas du tout le profil sans
compter que c'est pas vous qui
choisissez si je peux me permettre c'est
le gouvernement vivre et vous d'ailleurs
rien monsieur qui ressemble très fort à
thierry cariou qui va me donner le
papier donc ça mettrait c'est tout
n'essaie même pas de me convaincre mais
je n'ai pas à vous convaincre j'ai le
papier il n'y aura pas de véronika
loubry nine séverine ferrer ni cachemire
à nu tout puisque j'ai été désigné dans
le gouvernement
sinon pourquoi tu te serais pomponner
comme ça je suis papou bonnet ils vont
vous dire quand je me balade live mail
ou tv vous ici plus dragué quoi attendez
vous ils vous qui avez ça marche avec
moi j'suis pas emmanuelle bercot mois
d'août juste parce qu'il croit qu'il est
beau
oui bah voila je vous ai dit avec moi ça
marchera pas pourquoi nommer loti lui
fout tout bon pour qui bon ben je crois
que je prête